>> Thank you for
being here on time.
Welcome to everybody here.
And the reason we're
in this larger venue,
is for the videotaping of
Robert's talk, because I saw
in YouTube, he goes to Cornell
and Cornell does this elaborate,
one-on-one interview
with Robert,
talking about the work he does.
And it's like, "Oh, come on."
You know, "He went
to our school.
Why aren't we doing something?"
So -- and so though,
that's why [inaudible].
So, this room is built for
videotaping talks very easily.
And so, it's our pleasure
to meet Robert and I try not
to think about how far I go back
with Robert because we were --
I was working at Bell Labs.
In fact, I remember, I was
just minding my own business
at Bell Labs.
I was laying low that summer.
And this guy is knocking
at my door,
and he introduces himself
as Robert Hampshire.
And he was there as
a summer student.
And he, you know, he at that
time, he was an undergraduate
at the University of Cincinnati
in electrical engineering.
But you know, electrical
engineers in the 1990s,
felt a little adrift because
the internet had been built.
You know, "What do we do now?"
And so, and then, Frank Kelly
[phonetic] was visiting us
and he was talking
about internet --
you know, network economy.
And network economy,
economics, you have to look
at how many customers there are,
and how many customers can be
described by a queuing model.
So, the beginnings of
queuing and economics,
were starting right there.
And so, I said nothing, and
he told me he wanted to apply
for you know, Princeton's
Operations Research
and Financial Engineering
Department.
Okay? And then, little
did I realize
as someone who'd worked there,
you know, 2001 at Bell Labs,
when the summer was over,
we would both leave
and go to Princeton.
Okay? And so, he
got his PhD here
at Princeton University
Operations Research Financial
Engineering Department, and
then he went on to become,
first the assistant professor
at Carnegie Mellon which was
in Pittsburgh for a few years.
And then he went to the
University of Michigan.
And now he's a tenured professor
of the Gerald R. Ford School
of Public Policy, at the
University of Michigan.
And he doesn't work on
telecommunication problems.
He's taking queuing
theory over to look
at resource sharing issues in
the world of transportation,
and become an expert in
the area of smart cities.
So.
>> Okay, [inaudible].
Thanks, Bill.
[ Applause ]
>> Robert Cornelius Hampshire:
Alright, well thanks Bill,
for that great introduction.
And thanks for changing the
location of the seminar.
This is -- so, thanks
for coming over.
So, let me just jump
right into it.
So, I'm going to talk
about a collection of work
that we've been doing over
the last ten years or so,
related to reducing
congestion, pollution in cities.
And trying to make
them more livable.
And so, this is under a
broad rubric here I call Data
and Decision Sciences
for Parking Management.
This is one set of activities
that my research group
had been working on.
And so, for those of you
who are going to fall asleep
and like not pay attention,
I'll just give you the
punchlines right now.
So, what we're going to do is
a field experiment of pricing.
It's a spatial pricing
problem, related to parking.
And so, we actually
implement this in the field.
And basically, it's a test of
marginal pricing for parking.
Oh, okay. Let me
just pull that up.
So, the bottom line I
want to say is that, okay,
for any economists in the
room, so pricing works
to help align supply and demand.
It does work.
Even despite some significant
market imperfections
that I'll tell you about.
And it actually turns out that
if you can just get a few people
to change behavior in
a constrained system,
that you can actually
see a big out --
change in some output variables.
Okay? And here that was going
to be cruising and congestion,
is one thing we really
care about.
So, just small changes
in pricing can actually
make a big difference
in road congestion.
So, I'll show that.
And also, because of some --
there's quite a bit
of non-smooth behavior
in some of these prices.
So, I'll show you that
a reasonable supply
and demand curve for
a city over space,
actually has pretty big jumps
in what the equilibrium
prices look like.
So, you can be on one block, and
the best price is $5 an hour,
but an adjacent block, literally
will be 25 cents an hour.
That's the right
equilibrium price.
And so, you get these sort of
very non-smooth set of prices.
I'll talk about that.
And then finally, here
for cities, this --
think about on-street parking.
Really cities oftentimes
think about occupancy.
How many cars are parked?
But that's really not the
right thing to look at.
I'll show you that what
you want to look at,
is from the perspective
of the driver.
What's the chance that
when you show up to park,
there's a space available?
Alright? And a lot of cities
actually look at the occupancy
of spaces, but that's -- I'll
show you that's not the --
necessarily the right
thing to do.
Okay? So, these are
some punchlines
that I'll return
to, hopefully soon.
So, and like I said
here, the idea is that,
a little goes a long way.
So, what we're going
to do is modify prices
in some very elaborate
way, and it actually turns
out that the occupancy
changes only 1 or 2%.
But that corresponds to roughly
a 50% decrease in the amount
of time it takes people
to look for parking.
So, this is the idea of this
sort of congested system.
You can really make a big impact
by small changes on the inputs.
So, of course, idea of pricing
for roadways is not new.
Actually, even pricing
for parking is not new.
So, Vickrey back in the 50's,
actually has a whole paper
about parking and using
congestion pricing related
to on-street parking.
So, like I said, this
is part of a larger set
of activities we've been up to.
I'm not going to
spend much time.
We're doing some stuff AV's.
We're looking at travel behavior
impacts of on-demand mobility.
A lot of stuff now on
socioeconomic impacts
of automated driving systems
and driverless vehicles.
And a lot of stuff
about financing a
smart infrastructure,
plus like real options,
and so forth.
[Inaudible] and stuff.
So, I'm not going
to talk about that.
We also have lots of stuff
going on in bike share,
scooter sharing,
alternative modes
of vehicle ownership,
and so forth.
But I'm going to focus just
in the top-left corner,
the smart parking.
Alright so, let me just
jump into the motivation.
So, alright -- so,
of course, here,
road congestion is
certainly a big --
some people think a waste
of time, and annoying.
There's also a signal
of economic activity.
But it turns out that of
course, you guys know lots
of causes attributed to people
sitting traffic throughout
the day.
You know, one, 9% of all
driving time's actually spent
in congestion.
You know, so-called 42 hours a
year spent sitting in traffic.
And this comes at a huge --
well, 300 billion dollars
cost of congestion.
That's lost wages
and time, mostly.
But guess what?
Even though sitting in
congestion is really annoying
and costly, we all still do it.
Right? Because we
want to go to work.
We want to see our
friends, and so forth.
So, with that setting, it
turns out that you know,
we still do it because we
don't pay the full cost
of the externalities that
we're imposing on other people.
So, it's sort of the
hurting behavior --
you know, tragedy
of commons idea.
Alright? So, we don't really
pay our full [inaudible].
Some estimates, they're roughly
about 8 cents per mile is
actually a cost that you impose
on other people, due to the
congestion that you cause.
There's certainly
a lot of noise.
There's a safety risk per mile
that you impose on other people,
that you can kind of estimate.
This is from the literature.
And certainly, pollution risk.
This one's a little more
wonky because, well,
how do you price pollution as
an issue, but you might think
about that's a cost,
externality, that
you're imposing.
That you're not quite
internalizing.
So, also it turns out,
there's even more costs
that you're not paying
for, because guess what?
Most of the time, you park
at the mall, park places --
you park for free,
but guess what?
Those parking spaces
aren't free.
Certainly, there's a
cost that's attributed
for every trip you
make in the city,
there's a parking space waiting
for you on the other end.
There's some cost
associated with that.
And also, the cost to build.
If anyone's looked -- priced
out prices of garages, I mean,
there's a lot of municipal
finance in cities that take
out big bond issues to pay for
parking garages, to build space.
So, it's certainly not free.
So, you don't really
pay the full cost.
Either your trip when you're
driving, or when you park,
those are all subsidized by
other actors in the system.
So, as you guys know,
New York's --
this is researched
in New York, right,
but congestion pricing is
one-way theoretically to think
about ways to get
drivers to pay for some
of the externalities they're
imposing on other people.
Of course, Singapore and
other places have done this
for a long time, and they
probably have the most pure form
of this congestion pricing,
because they can do it
at the roadway level.
And the idea is you
know, try to --
have drivers pay for
this marginal cost.
But of course, there's
another version of this --
political backlash
to this, I guess.
I haven't kept track today
or the last couple of days
in New York, what's happening,
if they're going to move forward
or not, but certainly ten
years ago, when this came
up the first time, there
were certainly major backlash
about congestion pricing.
And cities like London
have a version,
and this is what New
York City's considering,
more like cordon pricing.
This is, when you enter a
region, a congestion region,
you pay, as opposed to the
pure, sort of Vickrey prices
where you're charging --
you're being charged for
the actual road segment
that you're going to travel on.
That's sort of the
first best kind of idea
that you want to
charge per link.
But there's other
approaches that do this sort
of cordon pricing and so forth.
So, let me get to parking.
Okay. So, one way you can
think about parking pricing,
is actually an alternative
to road pricing, okay?
So, one way to think about
it is that okay, every trip,
ends with your car
parked somewhere.
Alright? So, you may think about
parking pricing as some kind
of so-called second-best
approach to try to capture some
of the externalities
related to driving.
Okay? So, there's a body
of economic literature
that conceives about the
price of parking in this way.
You know, if parking's a million
dollars an hour, guess what?
You're not going to go park
-- drive and park there.
So, you're controlling
traffic -- congestion.
Okay? So, imagine there's
some price between zero
and a million dollars
that might make sense.
Okay? So, that's how we're
kind of framing this.
So, but the idea, "What
is that right price?"
And so, in some ways,
you might think
of the price equaling
the marginal social costs
for occupying this space.
Right? And so, this
includes the cost --
the searching cost that
you impose on other people.
While you're looking -- while
you're driving around looking
for a parking space,
you're really --
you're inconveniencing
lots of other people.
Maybe you should
somehow internalize that.
Certainly, the safety
risk, the pollution risk,
and other costs might --
you might want to try
to capture that as well.
And so, for example,
I think this was in --
this was in London, that roughly
estimated about every hour
that you were parked, you caused
about three to four other people
to look for a parking
space, okay?
And there's some time
costs associated with that.
So, this is some
of the sort of --
the empirical foundations we're
thinking about parking price
and a way to frame it as a
-- this congestion charge.
So, but I want to say,
a lot of the ideas
about congestion pricing, like
be it parking or road pricing,
assumes a lot about people's
knowledge and information flow.
For example, you know,
you're assuming that --
okay, one, drivers are making
rational decisions, okay?
So, we know parking's
sometimes irrational.
Some people they -- they
can always beat the system.
Most of your [inaudible] for
example, think they're better
than the average driver.
You know, they're -- and some
people think they're better
than the average person
at finding a parking spot.
So, they'll have these risk
behaviors that you know --
so, there's a question
here, "Okay,
do people actually
make rational choices
about looking for a space?"
Alan, I'm sure you're
good at finding a space,
better than anyone else.
I can imagine.
One, a driver's -- people
actually pay for parking.
Okay? Pricing only works
if people actually
pay for it, you know?
And also, in a lot of places,
you have a lot of visitors
who don't know how
much parking costs.
So, they're not making
their decision about whether
to make the trip, you know,
based on full information,
or where in a given city
to park, at what price,
as a mechanism of -- .
Like, for example, does anyone
here know, how much does it cost
to park on street in Princeton?
Say on Nassau Street, per hour?
>> Two-twenty-five.
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Oh, very good.
Okay.
>> No, I mean, they
just changed that.
It's like $8.00 or something.
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: It's $8.00 now?
>> I don't know.
>> Robert Cornelius Hampshire:
So, that's what I'm saying.
>> [Inaudible] based
on time [inaudible].
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Yes,
so a lot of this
foundation depends
on do people actually even know
the prices to react to them?
And that's the same
for road [inaudible].
And you assume people
can -- it's enforced.
And so -- so, okay.
>> It's perfect in Princeton.
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Oh,
enforcement is perfect
[inaudible].
That's true.
Okay so, here's where --
let me get to the meat.
So, here -- what we
did is, this was part
of a 20-million-dollar
federal pilot program.
I think that was matched
by the state of California.
So, like a 40-million-dollar
pilot program in San Francisco,
to actually implement a dynamic
-- a pricing scheme for parking,
that takes into --
with the goal is
to minimize the road
congestion associated
with people looking for parking.
And also, with the goal of
improving the vehicle speed
and flow on the roads.
Yes, so, ultimate goal of
reducing greenhouse gasses.
Like localize pollution that's
related to people looking
for parking and congestion, and
improving the traffic speeds.
So, the way this program,
worked, there's one part of it
that was -- we call it so-called
Demand Responsive Pricing.
The other as you see here,
it looks like they did
this now on [inaudible].
>> We have smart meters.
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Smart meters.
So, you rip out the old
meters and then you put
in so-called smart meters,
or you allow people to pay
by their cell phone,
or something.
So, we did that.
Here, longer time limits.
So, a pure market-based approach
for parking would actually
have no time limits.
You would just use price
as a mechanism to --
so, it's like a supply
and demand.
If you want to park longer,
that's fine, but you're going
to pay for it, you know?
And the other part was the
information environment.
So, this is their real-time
And the way we -- this was
actually implemented, it was --
this was implemented
in certain sections
of the city, that's the orange.
And then, other parts
of the city, it wasn't.
So, it's like a quasi-control.
So, this is kind of -- try
to control for economic --
macro-economic kinds
of activity.
So, you know, when the economy's
bad, people aren't going
to work, so the congestion's
down, right?
So, what we wanted to
do was have some areas
where we didn't control the
price, so that we can try to net
out the effect of the pricing.
>> What's the difference
between the orange and the blue?
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: So,
the blue are the areas we
didn't change the price.
Orange is where the
intervention was.
And I can tell you
more about that.
This is -- let me just
say that this is joint
with some collaborators.
We were actually on the
technical advisor committee
to the city to set
up this program.
And so -- and with someone
else named Donald Shoup.
Okay--
>> Let me ask you a question.
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Yes?
>> If I drive around and
around and pretend I'm looking
for the pricing, can
I erase [inaudible]?
>> Robert Cornelius Hampshire:
Yes, so I'll tell you.
So, here, I'll tell
you the pricing is not,
what I call, like
dynamic pricing.
It's not a real time
changing price.
We're only going to change the
price once every six weeks.
So, it's not like you pull into
a parking spot and then a --
then you know the price.
So, because there has to
be some price discovery
that it affects people's
behavior.
So, they need to kind of
know some predictability
about how much it cost.
So, that's [inaudible].
So, no. Your answer's no.
You can't-- .
>> So [inaudible] not important.
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: No.
Not at all.
Okay so, and I'll say
this later because we had
to get this past city council.
So, the pricing mechanism
had to be
such that it was
understandable and -- okay.
So, here, what I want to say is,
"Did this program actually
increase parking availability
and reduce search times?"
That's sort of the key question.
So, in some ways, it's
like a program evaluation.
We created some algorithms,
implemented them in the field,
they were in the field
for about four years,
and they [inaudible] did it,
had they achieved their goal.
Alright, and so again, the
two main pieces of this time
of day pricing, and this
real time environment.
So, actually had students
who built the first
version of this app.
It has real-time
information about parking.
And then the city
turned out to use
that in the full implementation.
Again, like I said
here, it turned out --
it's easier to control
in pilot areas.
There are roughly
about 6,000 spaces.
These are on-street spaces
that we actually change --
we had control of changing
the price of parking.
So here, what we did is we
want to adjust the time of --
pricing by time of day.
So, the way this is set up
is, there's a morning price,
afternoon price, and
an evening price.
Okay? So, those are the three --
so, it's not like a
continuously changing price.
It's just one -- and the idea --
so, I put this paper down here
because this is actually the
paper from my dissertation.
So, this is how I got into this.
This is how do you set --
this was actually in a
telecommunication network.
How do you set the price
such when someone shows
up to use the resources, there's
some guaranteed probability
that there's a resource
available, to use it?
That was the chapter
of my dissertation.
So, this work, years
and years later,
turns out to not use
that, by the way.
I mean, this is really
theoretical and not so practical
for implementation, but
this informed what was
actually implemented.
Okay so, we boiled down
the objectives to this.
The idea is that for each block,
we want to keep the occupancy
between some ban,
60 to 80% full.
Alright? And because that way,
you're utilizing the block.
Mainly people are traveling
for some value-added
activity or some utility.
They're shopping.
They're seeing their friends.
So, you want to make sure
there's space available.
But you want to make sure
there's not too many spaces
available, right?
And so, I -- so, we
actually shoot for this ban
about 60 to 80% full, okay?
And the way the pricing
algorithm works, is this.
So, in the previous six weeks,
we observe all the occupancies
on all the blocks in the city.
And for each block,
for each block,
we look over that
previous six weeks,
was the occupancy over 80% full?
If it was over 80% full, then
we just increase the price
by a quarter, for
the next period.
So, increase the price.
Maybe use -- you know,
discourage people
from parking there,
because we want to pull it
down between the
60 and 80% range.
Alright? But if, in the previous
six weeks, the occupancy's lower
than 60%, then we
lower the price, okay?
Now, here's the part where
it sort of theoretical model
of how you should change
your price, and [inaudible].
But you know, the
people implementing this
in the city were
like, "Okay, look.
Give us something that we
could actually make sense
of and communicate."
You know, so this was it.
We could only increase the
price by 25 cents per hour,
but we could decrease the price
by you know, 25 cents
or 50 cents.
They were fine with us
decreasing the price.
There's the increasing,
that's the problem.
Okay? So, the idea with
this, you're not supposed
to really try to read that.
It's just to show that
there's a flow of algorithm.
And so, this, like I said,
we do this over the time --
these three, time
bands: morning,
evening -- lunch, and evening.
So, let me get to punchline.
So, we had this pricing scheme.
And so, like I mentioned, one
of the key assumptions a lot
of time in revenue management
or pricing, is that the users
or people actually
know the prices.
And so, the city did a
major marketing campaign.
So, this is from the
San Francisco Chronicle.
And there were billboards all
over the city, at bus shelters,
a very large campaign,
to let people know
that this program's happening,
and that there's
an app available.
On that app, you
could see the prices
in real time, and so forth.
So, there was a big effort to
communicate this -- the prices.
So, the way this
worked is, for example,
and here's the Filmore area.
So, here, the brown
area for example,
is where there's low occupancy.
Okay? So, and red means
the occupancy's high.
Alright, so here's a
sort of before picture,
and if a block is between
you know, less than 60% full,
then we decrease the price
for the next time period.
So, here are the
corresponding price changes.
So, green in this picture
means we decrease the price
on those blocks.
Red means we increase.
Okay? So, this is --
so, we looked at the
previous time period.
Look at the average occupancy.
Then we change the price,
and then we see how those
prices affected occupancies
in the next time period.
Okay? So, here, the idea is
we want to move more and more
of these blocks into
the blue area.
So, this is how the
program worked.
>> Why you [inaudible]
green sometimes [inaudible]
red [inaudible]?
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: So,
the red should only
get increases.
Hopefully, the red
should only get increases.
If in this time period,
you were red,
then you should get
over here, increases.
So, over here, for increase.
>> Okay, [inaudible].
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Yes.
And the idea is to push
everything into the blue areas.
Okay so, here is sort
of a net change --
net changes over the
different neighborhoods.
So, this is over
12 price changes.
So, you can see [inaudible]
net -- red means on net,
that the price increased.
Green, on net, the
price decreased.
So, we did this -- this
is after 12 prices changes
with 6 weeks in between.
So, you see here, it's not
really like a price gouge.
[Inaudible] you know, there was
a big backlash to this program.
Like, "Oh, the city's just
gouging us for more money.
Revenue." Alright?
And so, you see, it's a
mixture of green and red.
So, some areas, the prices
decreased pretty significantly.
And some areas, it increased.
Yes, there?
>> How transparent
is the pricing?
Do people have to stop
and look at the meter
and read the fine point or--
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Yes.
>> -[inaudible] print
or is there --
are there big signs that say,
"This block is this much"?
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Yes.
>> "And this block
is this much"?
>> Robert Cornelius Hampshire:
That's a great question.
So, it's in the app.
So, if you, before you
leave home, look at the app,
you can know what the
price of parking is.
If you travel to that area
often, you can do some
of your own price exploration.
And so, maybe after six
weeks, then you understand.
You've done enough discovery.
That's kind of the premise
of why we exogenously changed
the price every six weeks.
We just say we do that.
We don't necessarily
optimally time
when we should change
the prices, for example.
But that's a great question.
Yes?
>> How much did it take
people to react to this?
Like, [inaudible]?
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Yes,
so this is a great question.
I'll get to that.
Just -- the question
about stabilizing.
Well, do these prices stabilize?
So, let me just say this.
So, actually, it
turns out, so --
that the prices were quite
insensitive to price --
I mean, the parking levels were
quite insensitive to price.
I'll say more about
that in a second.
But here's -- actually, it turns
out one-third of the blocks,
monotonically increased -- the
price increased over the --
this is over a 12
time change period.
So, they went up.
One-third went up monotonically.
The other -- another third
monotonically decreased.
So, the area just got cheaper
and cheaper and cheaper.
Some areas got more
expensive, more expensive.
But then everything
else in between,
actually bounced around.
Sometimes they go up,
then they go down.
So, you get some odd behavior
there in the equilibrium.
And also, what I say, there's
non-smooth spatial prices.
So, you'll get literally roads,
streets, blocks right next
to each other, that have
very different prices
after many changes.
After many price changes.
And that has to do with
maybe like amenities.
You know, where restaurants
are, versus where they're not,
but you imagine people's
walking utility should be smooth
over a space.
It should be a nice,
spatial thing.
So, that's still
actually a current mystery
that we're trying to look
at for spatial pricing.
And it turns out the average
revenue per meter went up.
Okay.
>> Go [inaudible]?
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Yes.
>> [Inaudible] So, I guess
our 1, 2 related that--
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Yes.
>> -you -- this looks
like an area
where I should decrease
the price.
I increased it, but
nothing really happened,
so let me do it again.
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Exactly, yes.
>> Okay.
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Yes,
I'm not going to go into it.
We went -- we have a whole
set of methodologies,
how to estimate this
-- price elasticities.
It turned out, it's
not easy to do
because there's some
reversion --
some issue with reversion
to the [inaudible].
If you guys want to know
more about that, we can --
I can say more about that later.
Okay so -- so here,
the idea was --
we observed that the occupancy
and the cruising levels
actually had changed,
but it was actually due to
our program, or was it due
to some other thing
that was happening?
And so, to do this -- to
do the actual analysis,
here's what we did.
This program had an API
-- or we had access --
since we were running,
we had access to data
over roughly a two-year period
about the average
occupancy on all the blocks.
Like I said, there's about
400 blocks in the program,
250 were in the pilot, 55 were
controls, and just to kind
of give you guys a sense
of how much parking is,
so the baseline before
we started the program,
was $2.00 an hour.
Two dollars an hour to park.
Okay? And so, for
all the blocks,
we have the occupancy
levels and the prices.
And that's from the
parking spaces perspective.
Alright so, this is
what the urban planners
and the transportation
planners were thinking.
They were like, "Oh,
the idea is to kind
of keep the average
occupancy between 60 and 80%."
Well, in this case, 85%.
It was sort in the literature.
We wanted to have occupancy
on average around 85%.
And they thought that that --
and they use that
as rule of thumb.
But it turns out just because
a space is occupied 85%
of the time, that's not the same
thing as saying, as a driver,
when I show up to park,
that there's a space
available 85% of the time.
Okay? This is sort
of the difference
between the spatial average
and the time average.
So, this is -- so what is the
experience of the drivers?
And so, this is --
okay, some good --
some queuing theory comes in.
This is a standard
problem in queuing theory,
that it was C here would
be the number of spaces.
We have some folks who
are arriving to park.
If the spaces are all
full, then here you drive
around until you can park.
Very simple model of parking.
Alright? And so, it turns
out that that's a standard --
if you assume things
are exponentially --
you know, [inaudible] on
arrivals, exponential amount
of time you wait here.
Was a very standard model.
Multi-server queue model.
And it actually turns out that
from the driver's perspective,
that probably that --
when you show up to park,
that there's a space available,
is this so-called
Erlang C formula.
So, you can write that down.
And from the parking
spaces perspective,
this is the fraction
that are going
to be occupied in the long run.
So, this kind of gives
you that dichotomy.
So, here's what we
ended up doing.
The data that we originally had,
I told you is the
hourly averages.
But what we did is we took
finer grained observations
of how much -- how many
spaces were available.
Okay? So, every five
minutes, we're collecting data
for every block, how many
people are parked there.
Okay? And I'll show
you why we do that.
So, here it turns out
the -- so we want to --
what's the hourly --
what's the relationship
with an hourly occupancy and the
probability of finding a space?
Like, I said, that's the
Erlang Blocking Formula.
But we have lots of data,
so can we actually
empirically verify or fit that?
So, what -- so actually,
what I end up doing is taking
that Erlang Blocking Formula,
and taking the log of it.
Okay? So, if you take the log of
this, Erlang Blocking Formula,
you get -- actually, you
can get a linear regression.
So, basically, what
I'm going to do is make
like a linear model, alright?
So, and I'll show
you why I'm doing it.
So, on the right-hand side,
are data that's related
to the -- what the spaces see.
These are like the
spatial averages.
But on the left-hand side,
is actually the driver
averages, okay?
So, I'm basically linearizing
the Erlang Blocking Formula,
and then running a
regression, to get a model.
So, it turns out that --
like I said, we had about
130 observations about --
for every block --
130,000 observations.
And so, you can actually fit
empirical model from the data,
about how if a block is 80%
full on average over an hour,
what's the corresponding,
over there,
probability that a
driver finds a space?
Okay? And of course, that's
[inaudible] the number
of spaces on that block.
So, if you have a really big
block, and it's, you know --
it takes a lot of -- a
really high occupancy that --
for the users to
experience full.
Right? If you have
a really big block.
So, that's going to
come in handy later.
So, let me move on.
So, next, the idea is that how
does this hourly occupancy data
that the city uses, how
does that map onto cruising?
They're searching for a space.
So, the idea is that you're
looking for a space to park.
If it's not available, then
you go searching around.
Okay? And so, what we do
is a very simple model.
Because we don't have --
we don't have sensors that track
all the cars in this study.
What we do only have the --
we can only see what's
happening at the space.
Is it full or not?
And we can see the dynamics
of how the block changes.
And so, we're going to use
that to infer how long it
took you to find a space.
Yes?
>> Don't you have an app?
[Inaudible] turn the app
on, and then you turn
on the GPS receiver and
[inaudible] you know everything
about the [inaudible] because
I went around or [inaudible]?
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: No, we don't.
[Inaudible]
>> Oh, you didn't go
there [inaudible]?
>> No, we didn't.
We should have.
We didn't do that.
We do have how many people
are actually using the app,
but we don't track the user.
We should [inaudible].
>> Can I ask why you didn't?
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Oh, no.
Yes.
>> [Inaudible] moral
[inaudible]?
>> Robert Cornelius Hampshire:
There's privacy reasons.
>> [Inaudible] never mind.
>> Robert Cornelius Hampshire:
Now, we have other work
where we actually, in the same
period, purchased a large set
of GPS data, for about a
million trips of people moving
around in San Francisco,
and we estimate how many
people are looking --
excessively looking for parking.
>> Where'd you get
that [inaudible]?
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: So,
someone else collected the data.
So, you can buy these data
sets as you [inaudible].
So, in this -- for this work,
what we did is a
very simple thing.
Actually, it's just
absorbing mark off chain.
I'll show you.
So, the idea is that you know,
[inaudible] each driver wants
to park in a given block.
They start there with some
probability there's a space.
If they can't find a space, then
they move to the adjacent block
with some probability and
try to find up a space again.
So, it's almost like a
geometric kind of trials.
And so, let me show
you -- where's my --
okay, I'll show you this.
You guys know [inaudible].
So, we have a transition matrix.
So, the idea is that the first
row is where you want to park,
where you actually are driver
and you end up parking.
But let's say you start at Block
Number 3, where probably 0.8,
80% [inaudible] there's
a space available.
If there's a space available,
you go to Row 1 and you park.
You absorb.
So, it's a simple
absorbing chain.
And so, we know they're
just simple, linear system
that can solve for
the expected amount
of time it takes you to park.
So, it's the -- this
is a very simple model.
Alright? Now, the first
row about the probability
of a space is available, comes
from the data that we collected.
So, we have that raw data.
We know the probability
for every block.
So, we compute this
absorbing chain,
and we get results like this.
So, this is real results
for Fisherman's Wharf.
And let's look at
the dark blue here.
This is the average number of
blocks that you had to cruise,
before you could
find a parking spot.
The orange here is the
probability that when you arrive
at that block, that
there's no space available.
Okay? So, for every --
so, this is aggregated
up to the neighborhood level.
But for every block, we
can say, [inaudible],
"What's the probability
that when you show up there
as a user, that there's a space?
And what's the probability
that when you-- ."
We also say, "What's
the average amount of --
average number of
blocks that you have
to search before you can
find an available space?"
So, that's -- and that's sort of
all driven by the empirical data
in this simply queuing model.
Okay. And we can do that
for various neighborhoods.
As so, this is the
so-called Marina neighborhood.
And it turns out
here at 6 o'clock is
when the meters turn
off in San Francisco.
Alright. Like actually, it turns
out they probably shouldn't
turn off, because there seems
to be a lot of demand,
potentially in the evening.
So, let me move on.
So, okay. So, the
first part of --
this first part was really
about how do you compute
the relevant quantities
that we want to use
in evaluation?
So, like I mentioned,
so, this program SFpark,
we changed the prices on lots
of blocks, and then we wanted
to evaluate whether
or not it reduced --
reduced the amount
of time in cruising.
The amount of time you took
to find a parking spot.
And we want to know, did it
also reduce the occupancy?
You know, did the blocks move
into this 60 to 80% range.
Okay? But before we could
evaluate that properly,
we had to create some
tools from Queuing Theory
that was the quantities
that we're going
to use in the evaluation.
Make sense?
Okay. When is this over, Bill?
[Inaudible] because we
started at 4:30, right?
>> Yes, yes, yes.
[Inaudible]
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Okay, [inaudible].
Okay, good.
>> Like [inaudible].
Yes, I'd say about
10 [inaudible].
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: About 10 [inaudible].
Okay, alright.
Okay. So, the next
part is really --
so, econometrics or
statistical evaluation, okay?
So, let me just --
this is a big picture.
Okay? Let me [inaudible].
So, these row -- I mean,
the columns represent here,
ten different price changes.
So, we had to -- this
evaluation time period.
So, roughly about six weeks
between each price change,
so this is ten price
changes, and then --
but we took baseline data,
before we did any
changes in price.
Okay? Now, what I want to show
you is that -- look at the --
in the top row, at
the top, the green.
So, we wanted to push
the occupancy of blocks
into this 60 to 80%
range, right?
So, the top is the control area,
and so, the percentage means
like here, roughly 40%
of all the blocks were
in the range that we desired.
That's how you read this.
Now, at the bottom, these
are all from the pilot area.
This is where we actually
did the interventions.
Okay? And so, the idea was that
we want to push more and more
of -- into this range.
So, it started at
about 34%, 32, okay?
But it ended like 36.
So, you say, "Oh,
did it do anything?"
You know? Yes, maybe
it didn't --
maybe people were too
inelastic, you know?
Did it work or not?
Alright. But then you also
look at the control area.
So, what we wanted to do was try
to make a rigorous comparison
between you know --
did the program --
can you attribute to the
program, an increased number
of blocks in this range?
Okay so, what we did -- end
up doing this is that we kind
of built -- we wanted to
look at a couple things.
One, the percent -- so,
the first model is really
about how many --
the percentage points
by which a block
deviates from the range.
So, 60 to 80% is the
range that we care about.
If the occupancy of
a block was say, 85%,
then that would deviate
by 5 points.
Okay? That's this first --
the first dependent
variable we care about.
And the other thing is the
number of blocks cruised.
Okay? So, what we
want to make sure is
that we're pushing more
blocks into this --
we want to decrease this
deviation from the range,
over time, when --
and want to see
if it decreases the cruising.
Now, the key thing that we
care about is the programs.
So, how many times did the
rates change for a given block?
Okay? Now, there's lots of
other factors that contribute
to occupancy and parking demand.
So, the so-called like
"neighborhood effects."
So, there could be
things occurring say
in the Fisherman's Wharf area
that could have happened,
that we don't maybe --
for example, we may not observe
things that could happen.
A parade came through
or they shut
down some streets in
that neighborhood.
Unobserved characteristics.
And also, those kind
of things that happen
at the block level, right?
So, maybe some of the
meters were disabled,
but we didn't observe it.
So, we want to be able to sort
of control for a lot of --
some of these unobserved
factors, okay?
So, what we end up -- so,
what we do -- oh, well.
Maybe [inaudible].
I won't -- let me go here first.
So, what we ended up doing
is Number 1, 2, and 3,
relate to the occupancy.
Okay? And what you
want to look at --
what we really care about
is these number of changes.
So, every time the price
changes, what happens to the --
how much close -- do you
get closer to that range.
So, a negative means that
every time the price change,
you get a -- our blocks are
getting closer to that 60,
80% -- 60 to 80%
occupancy range.
Okay? And this so-called
panel regression.
So, we look at one block
over many time periods, okay?
So, we have a lot of
observations from one block.
And so, you have to
take in account --
so, we take into account, time
of day, day of week, lots of --
we have lots of data so
we can sort of control
for a lot of these factors.
So, basically about mine.
These first three
models basically show
that when you change price,
well except these first two,
that when you change the price,
you are actually moving closer
to that range, but it's
really -- it's really small.
And over here, 4, 5, and 6,
are really looking at cruising.
So, every time you
change the price,
are you decreasing the amount
of distance that people have
to search to find the space.
Okay? And I'm going -- I will
claim here that the answer's yes
and it's going to
be significant.
Let me just -- but let me
show you something though.
So, and this relates
to your question that,
here are all the
ten price changes.
And the Y-axis is sort
of the percentage change
that you're moving closer
and closer to the target.
So, it turns out that early --
and the blur there is sort
of the confidence
intervals, alright?
And so, you can see early in
the program, that it's sort
of indistinguishable from zero.
That maybe there's
no big effect.
But as you can continue
to change the prices,
you actually get -- that's
when you get the impact.
So, we continue this
out for 20 time periods.
So, we actually -- this
program is still in effect now.
It was a pilot, but
now it's been scaled
up city-wide and so forth.
But the point is that it
take quite a while for --
we can interpret this.
It took a while for
people to actually respond.
That we can say people
responded to this program.
Okay? It wasn't until maybe much
later that we can feel confident
to say that this program
changed people's behavior.
But by a very small percent.
Maybe 2 percentage
points on occupancy.
Okay? But, and the same
thing here for cruising.
You don't start to get an impact
until much later
on in the program.
So, it turns out that even
though the average occupancy
only changed about
1 to 2 percent,
the corresponding change in
this cruising was around 50%.
So, it really decreased
the amount of time.
Even though there wasn't a lot
of cruising at the beginning,
we can attribute about 50%
of the decrease in the amount
of time you were looking
for parking to this program.
And to provide more
color, so this is --
yes, the map of San Francisco.
Actually, it turns out that
of the roughly 500 blocks,
only about 43 of them accounted
for about half of
all the cruising.
So, we kind of know this.
There's like popular
areas in the city,
that basically generate
most of the searching.
So, it's very localized.
And it's, yes.
So, this is very surprising.
Well, in some ways.
That -- it turns out
that this program,
we were changing the price
on roughly about 500 spaces.
But we could get
close to the same --
well, I don't want to say.
Actually, it only
turns out that about 43
of the blocks are
generating most of --
half of all the congestion.
And I think this
phenomena kind of holds.
And it kind of makes
sense to us.
Like Nassau Street, okay?
If you get Nassau Street right,
then you're really going to --
you know, get a big
bang for your buck.
Yes, and so there is a lot of
just evidence that you know,
when you turn the
meters off at 6 o'clock,
you really get this big spike.
So, people are just
waiting, you know, to park.
Once the meters turn off, then
you get a lot of this demand.
So, the prices are
doing something to sort
of control demand,
because you know,
why else would there
be this sort
of really big discontinuity
at 6 o'clock?
So, there's something
happening there.
[ Inaudible audience question ]
Oh, good question.
So, like Fisherman's Wharf is
not residential, but here, yes.
Here's like residential
parking potentially.
That's good.
So, let me just kind of
move a little bit faster.
So, like I said, let me just
summarize here that this is a --
[inaudible] field
experiment to try
to understand how this
spatial pricing works.
And I think the takeaway is,
I call it like a little
change goes a long way,
meaning that the occupancy
didn't change a lot,
but the cruising, we
can attribute to say
that did change pretty
dramatically,
in some nonlinear way.
We got the very -- variety
of responses spatially.
Yes, maybe the program hasn't
run long enough to get smooth,
kind of spatial prices or
not in the equilibrium.
But that's not quite
what we're seeing.
And then, we would
kind of really argue
that this average occupancy
is something that was
in the literature and something
that city planners
really just --
that's what the main
focus [inaudible].
On average, how full is it?
But we tried to make an argument
that really, you want to try
to look at it from the
person's driving perspective.
Was there a chance
that you'd get a space?
Yes, so that's more about that.
Let me just stop here.
Okay, so from the implementation
side -- so this program,
it turns out that
it was sponsored
by the Federal Highways
Administration.
And the program actually led to
replication in a lot of cities.
Not just in the U.S., but around
the world had implemented,
based on lessons
learned here and other --
the things they implemented
versions
of this, time of day pricing.
They tried to use some
of these principles.
So, yes. And so, then we
did a big road show in a lot
of different cities in the
U.S. to try to you know,
replicate this to
a lesser degree.
Here we put -- they put sensors
in every, single parking space.
There were 6,000 spaces.
They put an individual
sensor in each space.
It's very expensive.
So, there's a very lightweight,
light hardware versions of this
that don't use as many sensors,
or don't use sensors at all.
Maybe use cameras.
Maybe use parking meter receipts
to try to infer availability,
but there's certainly
asset-light versions of this,
because this program
is very expensive.
It was a 20-million-dollar
program.
It was matched, 20 million
dollars from the state.
So, a 40-million-dollar
program, that a lot of cities
and states don't
have that money.
So, a lot of the work has been
about how do you translate
this to other places?
And so, of course, this -- and
this now may have more residence
if you look towards -- this
is my editorializing now.
Towards AV's, autonomous
vehicles, or self-driving
or driverless vehicles.
Those terms are all the same,
but people want to
ask me about them.
So certainly, that has
implicate -- parking, you know,
there's arguments that
actually these vehicles won't
park themselves.
In fact, if they -- if
they're privately owned,
which could be a disaster,
they would just drive
around in circles, on the road.
They have the incentive because
they may run on electric motors,
that are quite efficient at
low -- relatively low speeds.
So, the idea you might actually
have vehicles that may bob --
you have an AV, it dropped
you off, and guess what?
It doesn't park.
It may just drive
around in circles.
Worse yet, it may collude with
other AV's to create congestion.
So, they can move [inaudible].
>> No collusion.
No collusion.
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: No collusion.
To conclude, to actually
drive slow.
Alright? Or it may drive
back to your house and park
in your garage, or
something like that.
So, this parking that
we'll continue to do,
actually moving forward,
we have current work
that really looks
the implications
for AV, autonomous vehicles.
And so, let me just
kind of wrap up here.
Thanks to the people at --
in the city of San Francisco
who we worked very closely with.
This is based on a set of papers
that we've published on this.
And I'll stop there.
So, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Okay, and [inaudible]
couple questions.
Yes?
[ Inaudible student question ]
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Say that again?
[ Inaudible student question ]
Yes, so the -- you're saying --
usually, they want to have
one available parking space
per block.
And that's -- yes, so if you --
that's close to the kind of
objective we're looking at.
If an average block has 12 to
15 spaces, if one of them --
if 14 -- you know, 14
are full, then you get
around you know, 80, 85% full.
So, that's kind of like
this similar criteria.
But you need much better
sensing to make sure
that there's only
one space available.
Yes.
>> The technology question.
If there are sensors that that's
where there are parking spots
available, is there an app
that will tell you
where to go to park?
The closest parking
or cheapest parking?
>> Robert Cornelius Hampshire:
Yes, so the app, from the city
and now there's a
host of other apps
that have availability
information.
So, if you either have the app,
you shouldn't look
at it while driving.
That's a problem.
But if it's integrated into your
car, some navigation system,
they could drop, you
know, directly to the --
direct you to the
available parking space.
Yes. So, the app we made
was voice activated, too.
So. There?
>> So, I'm thinking about --
and I'm not advocating this,
but I'm thinking about
[inaudible] resources
and some people argue
that, you know,
what would a private company
do if they [inaudible].
And I, for the first
time in a long time,
I flew Southwest Airlines last
week, and they have this model.
And I think of their business
model as being very similar
to this, which is you --
you have tiered pricing with
the goal being that you --
you want to sell all seats
but if you're the last seat--
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: That's right.
>> -it's going to be more
expensive than the first.
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Yes.
>> Right? Did you guys
look at any of the data,
because I know airlines
spend millions of dollars
on this type of research?
What's [inaudible]--
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Yes.
>> -[inaudible] they do for,
and did you look at that?
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Yes, you know,
part of what Bob mentioned,
we wanted the prices
to be transparent.
And so, if you do this sort
of inventory-based, prices --
it's a much -- you know,
as opposed to airlines,
you go to buy a ticket,
you don't know how much
it's going to cost.
That's one thing, but if you go
to park in the city and you --
once you park, you get
out and look at the meter
and it's you know, $100 an hour.
That's not a satisfactory
political outcome.
So, a lot of political
constraints.
So, yes, we didn't --
that's why we didn't go
that direction [inaudible].
>> Well, now that you've
finished with San Francisco,
I'm just wondering if you'll
apply this to La La Land?
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: What is that?
>> Princeton.
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Oh, La La -- okay.
Now, I would say here at San
Francisco, part of the --
any additional revenues
that will be generated
from this program, go
to improve transit,
and go to improve the BART.
That's the subway.
And MUNI. Because otherwise,
if there's no alternative mode,
then the pricing now takes on
another different character.
You know, it's the certainly --
and you have to think about
equity impacts of this kind
of -- for public good.
So, the way that San Francisco
got around this is any revenue,
you know, goes to
improve transit.
And transit's for everyone.
And there's subsidized
transit passes and so forth.
So, you just don't end
up with like BMW's parked
on the street, which-- .
>> [Inaudible] people
sitting on the street.
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Exactly.
Yes, so that's a big deal of --
when you're implementing
in other cities,
are there viable other modes,
or are you just really gouging.
And I'll -- let me just
say one other [inaudible].
These programs make it easier
and more convenient to park.
And for some cities,
that's not the objective.
That makes it easier for
you to drive your car.
And actually, in some ways,
that works counter to a lot
of cities sustainability goals.
Okay? So, I -- we're sort of
torn with just like, where --
doing this program, and it
makes it easier for you to drive
and more [inaudible],
but guess what?
They may not be the right
objective to actually go after.
So, we're working on that also.
>> [Inaudible] when you
took the logarithm--
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Oh, yes.
>> -of the probability.
Was that more just for
computational convenience
or because log will probably --
sometimes it interprets
[inaudible] information.
>> Robert Cornelius Hampshire:
Yes, no, it was mainly
for computational
convenience to get sort
of a nice, linear regression.
>> But I just wondered just --
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: That's a good point.
>> -the absence of information
theoretical [inaudible].
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Maybe not.
Yes, so logs with
probability, yes.
Maybe get the -- you
maybe get the [inaudible],
the negative with that.
Okay.
>> [Inaudible] Oh, before we
take off, [inaudible] reception
that [inaudible] on
the second floor.
>> Oh, excellent.
>> Robert Cornelius
Hampshire: Okay, thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Silence ]